bonjour christophe souk merci beaucoup
d'être ce matin en direct sur notre
antenne alors on le sait la saison
touristique s'annonce plutôt prometteuse
même si à cette menace du variant delta
beaucoup de difficultés pour les
restaurateurs qui ont dû fermer pendant
ces longues périodes de confinement sauf
qu'aujourd'hui finalement il y à un
nouveau problème qui s'ajoute aux autres
problèmes
ces problèmes du recrutement du
personnel qu'en est il pour vous oui
bonjour
effectivement on a un métier qui est
extrêmement compliqué un qui est très
physique
c'est pas un métier que l'on fait tout
le temps à vocation de moins en moins
d'ailleurs de personnes de faux par
vocation et ses sept mois de fermeture
les derniers mois faire l'auteur ont
fait réfléchir beaucoup de personnes
dont beaucoup de personnes vont décider
de dû revenir travailler
on avait aussi une masse étrangères qui
venaient en service en cuisine qui
n'aura qui n'est pas revenu on a ce
problème qui va être un mot naji le
début d'une problématique va être très
très forte en france on est en train de
je pense juste de découvrir la partie
immergée de l'espèce de l'iceberg
oui parce qu'en fait ce que vous nous
expliquer c'est que le personnel
qualifié et et parfois saisonniers a
décidé de changer de voie pendant
pendant le confinement oui c'est ça
c'est exactement ça alors on aime un
problème c'est qu'il faudrait peut-être
pouvoir les payer plus de manière à ce
qu'ils reviennent chez nous quand vous
voyez que déjà la masse salariale chez
nous c'est 30 % de nos dépenses que nous
avons des sociétés en battant qui sont
passés de 15% de rentabilité à 3 4 % de
rentabilité
on a demandé à l'état de faire un effort
au moins sur les charges patronales de
manière à pouvoir parce qu'ils cherchent
à la réal appartiennent aux salariés
mais au moins aux charges patronales qui
sont une taxe des taxes qui sont
prélevées directement sur en local ou en
région ou en national de manière à nous
aider à pouvoir augmenter les salaires
de nos salariés sans chant aussi qu'il
faut que vous préciser qu'une ville
comme nice ils voient des superbes
images du cours saleya les les logements
sont de plus en plus cher et que
malheureusement les salaires ne peuvent
pas suivre parce que nous chefs
d'entreprise on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas suivre l'autre
problème c'est qu'il faut pouvoir loger
ce personnel est évidemment à nice étant
une ville touristique est les loyers
flambent et aussi un problème de fond de
la gorge parce qu'il est remarqué on a
là la mère d'à côté la montagne de
l'autre j'ai déjà très compliquée pour
pouvoir bâtir des bâtiments est
effectivement d'un problème de
disponibilité d'appartements mais qui
n'est pas que de profession il ya
beaucoup de problèmes aussi au niveau du
btp et 2 bat c'est le tarif parce que
l'offre et de la demande fait que les
appartements malheureusement ou même les
chambres sont devenus extrêmement cher
et malheureusement nous n'avons pas la
rentabilité nécessaire pour pouvoir
suivre cette flambée des prix les
conséquences c'est quoi ces des salaires
plus élevés ce sont les personnels
qualifiés maintenant qu'ils mettent leur
carte en avant et non plus vous qui est
imposé les des barèmes de salaire si
vous voulez on a on va dire qu'on a un
petit peu les salariés un petit peu
dirigeants que sur lequel il a fallu
faire un effort financier pour être sûr
qu'il reste ou qui portent pas la
concurrence qui ne changent pas de pays
et puis ensuite il ya les salariés avec
les premiers salaires les premiers
niveaux échoue c'est cela qu'on n'arrive
plus à trouver
c'est à dire que auparavant un étudiant
trouvé tout à fait normal de faire une
saison en restauration enchaîné quand
ils pouvaient avec les la récolte du
raisin dans les vignes aujourd'hui ce
sont des métiers qui ne leur paraissent
plus suffisamment facile et accessible
physiquement pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
le faire
quelles différences quelles conséquences
concrètement sur sur le service
alors le sait le service est quoi bein
aurait dû nous heures d'ouverture je
vous donne un exemple j'ai cet
établissement
voilà moi j'ai cinq établissements il me
faudrait cent trente salariés
aujourd'hui j'en ai que 92 donc il me
manque tellement que je ne peux pas
ouvrir certains des établissements le
midi donc je vous remets établissements
qu'à partir de 16 heures parce que je
n'ai pas suffisamment de salariés pour
pour les ouvrir midi et soir et alors il
ya aussi une solution c'est pôle emploi
que fait l'agent ce justement pour
essayer de remédier à ce manque de
personnel ne me lancez pas sur le sujet
chère madame
ses talents ce qu'est qui doit s'occuper
à priori de vous en voyez l'exemple
personnel comme ça ça restera que
personnel est bon pour nos oignons de
l'umih je fais avec un des
collaborateurs nous avons envoyé 20
demandes au cv les plus récents en
hôtellerie restauration disponible sur
le site de pôle emploi
sur ces vingt demandes qu'on a fait on a
eu une seule réponse d'une personne qui
dit oui mais moi je cherche un stage les
19,9 autres n'ont jamais répondu
voilà donc toute façon si simple pôle
emploi pour nous en restauration
il ya beaucoup de volonté apparemment du
côté gouvernemental et que j'admire
par contre je pense qu'il ya vraiment un
problème de liaison entre les
professionnels et ceux qui réellement ou
pas réellement chercher un emploi
alors comment faire pour que ça ça
remarche correctement et surtout avant
la saison touristique dans l'immédiat je
pense qu'il faut que l'état nous écoute
sur le problème de la décharge qui dias
sur les salaires on est en france je
peux comprendre qu'on a un pays plutôt
social où on est là pour aider les plus
les plus démunis et les plus faibles
mais à un moment donné on peut pas
demander à des chefs d'entreprises qui
sont eux mêmes déjà dans la difficulté
qui viennent d'avoir un an et demi de
grosses difficultés avec des
rémunérations extrêmement basses qui ont
déjà des sociétés qui sont sur un point
critique au niveau du cash sur demande
et en plus de faire un effort parce
qu'on ne pourra pas le faire donc il
faut absolument que le gouvernement nous
aide
là il faut qu'on parle de la tva
remettre la tva à 5,5 comme elle l'était
auparavant et il faut arrêter de prendre
notre argent pour aider la nation au
niveau sanitaire
on peut plus et la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il faut veut en faire un geste sur
les charges patronales
parce que même chose ça devient
extrêmement compliqué et c'est très
dissuasif pour tout le monde
les clients sont au rendez vous est ce
qu ils font preuve de patience alors les
clients sont au rendez vous je remercie
excusez moi je vais très communautariste
mais je remercie des niçoises et les
niçois parce que vraiment ils sont
extraordinaires
ils ont de suite quand nous avons ouvert
ils ont de suite joué le jeu je vois mes
amis dakar d'eau qui pense en même temps
en fond d'écran
honnêtement nous avons des vrais
professionnels sur la côte d'azur et sur
10 particulièrement est vraiment les
clients sont là merci à eux
même si nous tournons qu'à 70 80 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires habituel
merci parce que ça nous fait c'est la
marche qui fait entre rester vivant et
venir à disparaître
donc grâce à eux pour l'instant nous
restons vivants et nous commençons de
superbes saisons d'aidé message bien
reçu merci beaucoup christophe s'occupe
de nous avoir livré votre témoignage ce
matin dans la matinale verte et france